yeah welcome to my
webinar with the title recovery of
selfie dna
using the kai symphony circulating dna
kit
my name is alexander wolf and i am the
technical lead for the liquid biopsy
portfolio
in molecular diagnostics at tiagin and i
would like to give you a general
overview about
the scanning and very interesting topic
of liquid biopsy and will also focus
on some data from the fully automated
purification
of celery dna using the kaia symphony
instrument
here's a regulatory disclaimer for this
webinar and the applications presented
here
are for research use only not for use in
diagnostic procedures
what does liquid biopsy means it's a
non-invasive or minimal invasive
technology
in most cases a blood collection for
sampling and analysis of molecular
science as diagnostic and monitoring
tool for diseases
it's a clear contrast to tissue biopsies
and has the potential to complement or
even replace the tissue samples
liquid biopsy can be divided into three
major domains
first circulating tumor cells floating
through the bloodstream in very rare
numbers
therefore most challenging to purify and
concentrate
but with the potential to obtain the
complete genetic information
in the form of the genomic dna as one as
well as
all types of rnas from a living cell
second domain are the exosomes that
means
microvesicles shed into the blood body
fluids
and transport mainly the cell free rna
fraction between cells
the third fraction is the circulating
cell free nuclear aces
mainly the dna and highlighted on this
slide here by
the red frame which will be the focus of
my talk today
the surface dna is released from dying
cells into the bloodstream
in more detail it's a genomic dna of a
death cell which is strongly degraded
by dnases into short fragments with a
half-life of several minutes in the
bloodstream
currently liquid biopsies on the way to
transform our health care tremendously
despite the already existing success of
liquid biopsy
an example from non-invasive prenatal
testing or oncology
the application is still at the
beginning of its revolution
this slide summarizes several aspects
which illustrates the major benefits of
liquid biopsy
which should hopefully convince you of
the future potential of this application
i will shortly emphasize a few ones
compared to tissue biopsy it's obviously
safer and less painful for the patient
therefore the compliance of a patient to
undergo a simple blood draw
will increase the potential of an early
detection and close monitoring of
diseases
for physicians a real-time treatment
response monitoring
will allow increased insights on disease
progression in combination with a faster
development of new therapy options
pathologists will face a faster more
cost efficient processing and will
obtain in parallel the complete
heterogeneity of a disease state
because a blood sample reflects a more
homogeneous sample type compared to a
biopsy section
analysis of the origin of selfie dna
extracted from a plasma sample revealed
that most dna molecules derive from
hematopoietic cells
which is not surprising because it
simply reflects the high likelihood
that dying leukocytes release its dna
into its surrounding liquid
next it depends on the size the cell
metabolism
and blood circulation of an organ how
much selfie dna is found in the
bloodstream
as indicated on the right figure by the
lung liver
or intestine
based on this knowledge this is also
true for the fetal dna
shown here on the left side with the
advanced stage of pregnancy
increased amounts of dna from the
placenta is released into the mother's
blood
and more than 20 percent can be found
before bills
the same can be detected for cancer
patients tumor
size blood supply but also the therapy
status of a patient
is reflected by the amount of
circulating human dna in the bloodstream
interestingly also the total self dna
amount varies for cancer patients and
often reflects the overall
health or disease status
based on these findings the striking
success of non-invasive
prenatal testing in the last year can be
easily explained
and non-invasive primary prenatal
testing is an essential part of prenatal
screening today
here the pre-analytical and analytical
procedures
are well harmonized and validated and
will most likely
largely substitute amino sentences
within the next few years
or at least will further reduce these
invasive diagnostics
which may are only required after
positive test results from the liquid
biopsy-based essay
focusing on monogenetic disorders or
chromosomal aberrations
also at the beginning highly expensive
and not reimbursed by the heels
insurance
hundreds of thousands of women decided
for the blood-based test to avoid the
invasive procedure with residual risk of
fetal loss
and currently in many countries the
healthcare systems consider
or already pay for the monophases
prenatal testing
for risk pregnancies and discussions are
even ongoing to expand the test to each
pregnant woman
due to the highly convincing results of
the companies of the companies who offer
liquid biopsy-based tests
the next field which is on the road to a
routine application is oncology
at the moment the selfie dna based
analysis
is often used complementary to the
tissue biopsy for monitoring the
therapeutic response and resistance
but the data reveal that the selfie dna
analysis from a plasma sample has the
potential to identify
rare mutations often responsible for
metastasis and therapeutic
therapy resistance much earlier than the
biopsy or imaging methods like ct
this is indicated here in this figure by
the richly colored
circulating tumor dna in the blood tube
on the lower left side
which represents the complete
heterogeneity of the tumor mutation
few therapy dna molecules already
comprising mutations
responsible for for primary and later on
secondary resistance
may present in the filled blood samples
collected already at the beginning of
the targeted therapy
in combination with the more frequent
sampling easily possible for a simple
blood draw
a faster and more precise prognosis of a
therapy response is possible
therefore i think in near future a
targeted therapy for cancer patients
without an accompanying liquid
biopsy-based test is hardly imaginable
now i will switch to the challenges of
the therapy dna workflow this slide
shall illustrate the importance of
standardized workflows for surface dna
applications
the pre-analytical workflow starts with
a blood collection and sterilization
the cell-free dna of interest in example
the fetal or mutant
dna as in the examples before is present
in a large background of maternal or
wild-type dna
therefore it is of highest importance to
stabilize the therapy dna fraction after
rod collection
and prevent in parallel the release of
genomic dna from leukocytes
a dilution of the target surface dna
with background dna will negatively
impact the sensitivity and specificity
of the downswing assays
based on this knowledge usage of selfie
gain aids stabilizing blood collection
tubes is highly recommended
because many cases a transport of the
blood collection tubes
for several hours or even for several
days from the physician's office to the
diagnostic laboratory is not unusual
only in large hospitals where short
transportation time at cooled conditions
for one to two hours
between blood collection and plasma
generation can be guaranteed
the usage of edta tubes is a reliable
option
next it should be defined a clear plasma
generation a generation procedure
an example one low speed spin to
separate the plasma from the cell
fraction
or alternatively a second spin to remove
potential residues of larger cell or dna
fragments should be considered
and carefully tested in context of the
clinical assay outcome
at which temperature and how long shall
the plasma be stored before subjected to
certain dna purification
here as well a standardized standardized
scheme is recommended to ensure a high
reproducibility of the results
international standards for isolation of
circulating surface dna from plasma are
available
now which support and guide users for
the establishment of standardized
workflows
the next step in the pre-analytical
workflow is the extraction process
here i would like to emphasize that the
choice of the therapy dna extraction kit
also plays a major role for the
reliability of the ether result
completely independent of the extraction
efficiency between different kit
providers
each chemistry will have its bias on the
nature of the
eluded dna an example it may impact the
size distribution
the integrity of the double-stranded dna
or it may favor
defined at g-series sequences in the
genome
all of this factor may affect it as a
result
additionally of course the fa itself and
the data analysis
have to deal with the specific detection
of the target surface dna
in a huge background of maternal or wild
type
sulfur dna
the major challenge of helpful dna
analysis
is the low concentration of dna found in
plasma and the subsequent alloy
which is transferred into the downstream
assay this is
indeed a clear drawback compared to
cells or tissue samples as sample
material
where the dna input into the downstream
assay is a rarely
limiting factor but here we talk about 1
to 50 nanograms dna
per ml plasma in most instances only
about 1 to 10 nanograms
resulting in only a few molecules as
biomarkers present in a sample
because you have to consider that your
target dna that means the fetal or
mutant set of dna
is only present a few percent and in the
background dna
the second challenge is a highly
fragmented dna while the extraction must
focus on an
on an efficient recovery of small dna
dna fragments below 200 base pairs due
to this challenge it becomes clear that
the question on the slide here 500
microliter plasmas is enough
as often used for genomic dna extraction
are not compatible with the required
sensitivity
of the downstream assays for selfie
this issue must be addressed by input
volumes in a range of 2 to 4ml usually
but even up to 10ml or higher as
requested by customers
in parallel the therapy dna has to be
extracted quantitatively from plasma and
diluted in the low elusion volume to
concentrate
dna but even then
the low concentration of approximately
0.1
to 1 nanogram selfie dna per microliter
alloy
makes a quantification using
spectrophobic methods like nanorob
impossible likewise quantification by
analysis of site distribution profiles
is usually not recommended due to the
limited sensitivity of the essays
realtime pcr or digital pcr are the
preferred options for ally
for a reliable quantification but even
for the pcrs the bias in the total
quantification
an example due to the choice of the
target or amplifi
amplicon size should be considered
that's why we often prefer
only a relative quantification to a
reference method or reference conditions
to assess the extraction efficiency
now based on this information the
requirements for an ideal cfdna
isolation method can be extracted
these are a fast and straightforward
procedure to address
the increasing sample numbers in the
laboratories we are talking about a
throughput of a few samples per day
up to several hundredths per day even
thousand samples per day is not unusual
an easy handling of multiple samples in
parallel
addressed by a fully automated
extraction process with limited hands-on
time and tracking of each sample
an extraction process for different
sample input volumes
to address the individual needs of the
fa sensitivity
of course an efficient extraction of
efficiency focusing on the small dna
fragments
to ensure the detection of the lower
abundant target genes in the subsequent
airsafe
and elevates containing highly
concentrated surface dna in an excellent
quality
to be compatible to a broad range of
downstream applications
which are usually ngs or digital pcr
now kai engine offers several solutions
for therapy dna excretion and i would
like to focus on the two most important
ones
a manual expression kit and an automated
kit running on a dedicated instrument
the manual one the chi amp circulating
nuclear acid kit allows a flexible
starting volume from 1 to 5
ml plasma to give the maximum detection
sensitivity
to handle the large processing volume
tube extenders for the mini columns
and the vehicle and device is integrated
in the workflow
the robust procedure helps to minimize
sample-to-sample cross-contamination
and increases user safety when handling
potentially
infectious samples the simple procedure
is suitable for simultaneous processing
of up to 24 samples and less than 2
hours
a flexible dilution volume of 50 to 150
microliters can be applied
if higher nucleic acid concentrations
are required the illusion volume can be
further reduced
as low as 20 microliters
the next slides will focus on the
automated tf dna extraction
which is highlighted here on the slide
with a red frame
due to the strong increase in sample
numbers and due to the need for
standardized workflows there is a high
demand for an automated
expression of surface dna the child
symphony circulating dna kit
offers two sample input volumes 2ml and
4ml
and ensures in parallel a throughput of
96 samples in 5 to 6 hours
solution volume is 60 microliters
compared to the manual kit a complete
new chemistry and beats was developed
dedicated for the therapy dna extraction
a design goal for the new kit
development was an equivalent
performance to the manual kit which is
as fast as a gold standard in the market
the automated selfie dna extraction kit
runs on the kaia symphony sample
preparation instrument
the instrument is well established well
established in the research and
diagnostic field for many years
manifold applications run on this
platform like genomic dna extraction
from whole blood buffy code
or ffpe tissue samples as well as
extraction of dna and rna from different
viruses and pathogens
therefore we decided to expand the
existing portfolio of the instrument
to the surface dna application
the child symphony sp unit can be used
as standalone sample extraction unit
or can be combined with an assay setup
for fully automated preparation of a pcr
the instrument supports a flexible
sample loading from 1 to 96 samples
split into 4 batches each of
1 to 24 samples for each batch a sample
carrier rack with up to 24 samples can
be processed consecutively
in one integrated run resulting in a
maximum of 96 samples
the fifth carrier rate is available for
internal controls
or in case of the circulating dna
application to provide the protein sk
volume
the instrument also allows a continuous
sample loading for batches 1 to 4
with an individual protocol selection
each sample runs through automatic
barcode reading uploading of the sample
carrier racks to ensure traceability
traceability and safety is also
implemented for the pre-filled reagent
cartridges
which contain the buffers magnetic beads
and enzymes
for each application a specific
chemistry was developed and pre-filled
into the cartridges before sealed to
ensure a long shelf life of the kids
the seal set which is part of each kit
allows to
allow the reuse of an open reagent
cartridge for several weeks
and thereby ensures the flexibility and
sample numbers to run
each graph is backward labeled
individually and detected by the
instrument before the run
which allows an easy use safe handling
and a traceable documentation
this figure depicts a generic the
generic extraction workflow on the child
symphony
the big base nucleate acid extraction
ensures high yields and recovery rates
the excellent purity of the alloys
support the compatibility and
sensitivity of the downstream
applications
on the left hand here of the figure the
sample buffer and beads are distributed
in a regular
vessel then using a magnetic rod
protected by a rod cover the beads are
collected and bind quantitatively to the
rod cover
then the beads can be simply transferred
into into a new reaction well
in which new buffer is already dispensed
by the four pipetting channels of the
instrument
the beads can be easily released into
the liquid when the magnetic rod is
separated from the rod cover as shown
on the right side by up and down
movement only of the red cover the beads
are mixed homogeneously in the
processing volume
and thereby ensures the high efficiency
during the bind wash and dilution step
on the instrument
this slide shows the extraction workflow
for the selfie dna application for the
standard protocols for 2ml and formal
sample input volume on the child
symphony
2ml protocol starts with a binding step
which contains an aliquot of 2ml sample
volume
binding buffer protein sk for the
gaussian of dna 14 complexes
and the magnetic beads after binding of
the dna to the beads
the beads are subjected to three wash
steps before the purified therapy dna is
released into solution
during the during the illusion step
the new dedicated chemistry for therapy
dna extraction combines many advantages
first addition of only the low volume of
binding buffer to the sample
results in a reduced overall processing
volume which allows
a higher throughput compared and example
to a chartropic silica based
extraction the other advantage is that
all steps
occurred at root temperature and that
the new beads shall reduce that volume
during the allusion step
difference to the formula protocol is
indicated here by the dotted line
after separation of the beads from the
fifth aliquot of 2ml sample
the beads are transferred into a new
vessel which contains the second aliquot
of 2mm sample
binding buffer and protein sk that means
that binding of dna from the second to
an l-sample aliquot
takes place to the same beads which
already carries the therapy dna from the
first summer early quote
after binding of the therapy dna the
beats run through the three wash steps
before the illusion takes place
hope that this scheme also illustrates
how we could address high input volume
protocols up to 10 ml
we simply run through consecutive
binding steps and two amino sample early
quartz using the same bead portion
due to the very low concentration of
cell-free dna found in plasma and urine
saturation of beets with dna is not a
limiting factor
as a result of strong increasing
requests for such high input volume
protocols by customers
we currently are working on the release
of a standard protocol for 6ml
80ml and 10ml sampler input volume in
near future as well
on the next few slides i would like to
sensitize you to important aspects of
the assessment analysis
of selfie dna this slide shows two side
distribution profiles of selfie dna
analyzed with an agilent high
sensitivity chip
the upper one shows the prof profile of
surface dna
extracted from 4ml plasma in blue
and from 10ml plasma in red
the blue curve is already at the limit
of sensitivity of the sa which makes
clear that the reliable quantification
cannot be recommended
even the blank line don't indicate a
failed extraction but may reflect the
donor with the low concentration of
selfie dna plasma
which is then under the limit of
sensitivity for this essay here
on the other hand the red curve reveals
a nice size profile with a major peak
at approximately 170 base pairs
indicating the surface dna fraction
coiled around the histone complex
and therefore protected from dna's
digestion
even the second peak and the third peak
is visible which represents a d
and three nucleosome complex moreover at
the level of a
larger marker peak around ten thousand
base pairs larger dna fragments are
visible
which may be traced back to larger dna
cfdna molecules
publish an example for inflammatory
diseases for cancer
but with broader peak may also represent
genomic dna
from leukocytes which then would rather
reflect a reduced plasma quality
it should also be considered that these
size profiles only focus on the double
stranded dna present in the elevate
signals run a dna with a higher
fragmented pattern as revealed by
specific libraries which focus on both
double-stranded and single-stranded dna
is not visible here but have most likely
a significant impact on the total
therapy dna yield
this rule gives you a first example of
the bias each analysis or quantification
method has
hardly avoidable due to the low
concentrations of cell-free dna
which makes direct and easy
quantification not possible
and therefore results in only a limited
number of analysis methods available the
lower right figures
merge the therapy dna size profile
generated from
a urine in blue and from plasma in red
both from form has sample input for
urine
next to the prominent peak at 170 base
perth
an additional peak with a broad range
from
20 to 100 base pairs interrupted by the
lower marker peak is visible
these two peaks may reflect the selfie
dna fraction derived from plasma
highly fragmented during the glomeruli
transfer
and the fraction derived from the
urinary system
based on our knowledge working with
surface dna from urine is most
challenging
mainly due to the high need for
stabilization to prevent the release of
genomic dna from cells present in urine
and in parallel to prevent the fast
degradation of surface dna
in urine which takes place immediately
after sample collection within a few
minutes
but usage of standardized workflow which
address both issues
makes during to an easy and then high
volume available
and complete non-invasive sample
material
a robust and sensitive quantification
method for cell free dna is a pcr
we use for quantification a housekeeping
gene the multi-copy gene for 18f
ribosomal dna
amplifying a short amplicon of 66 base
pairs to cover as much as possible from
the fragmented surface dna fraction
the figure here illustrates the high
variability in therapy dna amounts
which shows in this case here a thousand
fold thousand-fold difference
from donor to donor in this experiment
including a sample size
of 48 single donors this illustrates
that usage of an absolute quantification
is not possible
to evaluate the extraction efficiency
for an individual sample
that's why we usually run a reference
method to calculate the success
of the extraction process here the
automated chiral symphony circularity
circulating dna kit on the x-axis was
compared to the gold standard in the
market the manual cayenne circulating
limited execute
shown on the y-axis the 18s copies were
plotted for each donor which result in a
comparable
total cell free dna extraction
efficiency for both kids
for a broad range of selfie dna
concentration
in the last year several providers from
internal controls for selfie dna offer
solutions to control the complete
workflow
starting from the dna extraction process
while the downstream essay unfolds the
final data analysis
despite the clear advantage to run for
each sample and
independent control partic in particular
due to the
known challenges of the very low and
variable cfdna concentrations
it should be considered that these
internal controls should be rather used
qualitatively than quantitatively that
means
they can give you a clear yes or no
answer regarding the success of the
workflow
but due to their expected bias
concerning the extraction efficiency
of the artificial dna depending on the
use extraction kit or chemistry
the recovery of the artificial dna must
not mimic
the extraction efficiency for the
endogenous surface dna
for the used extraction kit that's why
we trust only on the results generated
with real plasma samples and the
corresponding endogenous surface dna
fraction
now compared to the previous slide which
focused on the total therapy dna yield
these data should give you an example
how to evaluate the extraction
performance for low abundance genes
this aspect is most important because
usually users are rather interested in
the target selfie dna that means the
fetal or mutant biomarkers
which are present in only low ratios in
the background of cell free dna
of few percent or even lower
the abafikanya shows female plasma
spiked with low amounts of male plasma
to mimic a sample type with different
ratios of a low abundant surface dna
in large background by analyzing y
chromosome-specific genes
the multi-copy gene the 14 as well as a
single copied gene
sry1 using droplet digital pcr
as read out we phil's calculated a limit
of detection
because we had to consider a background
noise of non-spiked female plasma here
here we calculated a limit of detection
indicated by the red line
of two microliters male plasma diluted
in
2ml female plasma shown on the x-axis
which current corresponds to seven
copies this 14
per pcr well on the y-axis
the lower-right figures result from the
same experimental design
that means the analysis of
y-chromosome-specific genes at the limit
of detection
in the normal therapy dna background
used as a model for
for a reliable detection of
low-abundance genes depending on the
sample input volume
female plasma will spike again with male
plasma from different plasma volumes
ranging here from 1 to 10 ml to ensure
a reliable detection of this 14 female
plasma was spiked with a
2 times limit of detection of this 14 to
minimize risk of dropouts for the low
plasma portfolio
the left figure on the upper right side
for detection of this 14 reveals a
reliable extraction at the lower limit
of detection
and in addition a linear increase in
yield for the elevated input volumes
up to 10 and 10 ml plasma
the red circle here at form l input
shows a comparable extraction efficiency
obtained to the reference
the cayenne circulating the great acid
kit
interestingly when the same n-waves were
analyzed in parallel for the presence of
the second law abandoned gene
sry1 which is shown on the right figure
the single copy gene sry1 was analyzed
below the calculated limit of detection
therefore only a hit rate study that
means the presence of droplets was
executed for the different import volume
using lower classmen infrastructures
resided in an unreliable detection of
positive profits in digital pcr
whereas sensitivity of the sa can be
increased by using the highest input
volume of 10 ml for the selfie dna
extraction on the chi
symphony these data highlights once more
the advantage of an
increased sample input volume on the
detectability of lower bound machine
such an experimental setup is very close
to the characteristics of clinical
standards and therefore suitable for a
sensitivity assessment of the complete
workflow
which often focus on the sensitivity of
the downstream essay
these data hopefully convince you that
also the choice of the selfie dna
extraction kit
and the consideration of the quiet
thumbs input volume plays a major role
to achieve the needed
overall workflow performance
yeah i would like to finish my talk with
a short summary
circulating selfie dna is a new star
arising in the field of molecular
diagnostic with a huge potential for an
early and straightforward detection
of genetic aberrations present and
example in pregnancies cancer or
transplantation
but address already existing but also
the strong increasing demands for
reliable and automated surface dna
extraction process
combined with the high throughput
kaiogen developed the kai symphony
circulating dna kit
that is tablet for several years now in
the market
its pre-filled and barcoded reagent
cartridges ensure a safe
and ease of use in a diagnostic
environment
the kit was verified for purification of
surface dna from human plasma and urane
from 2ml and formal sample volume
it allows the generic use of plasma from
non-stabilized as well as therapy dna
stabilized blood collection tubes
and the dedicated surface dna chemistry
ensures an efficient extraction
efficiency
for highly fragmented dna with the focus
on law of
dna targets
now many thanks for your attention